nouveau rebondissement dans le dossier
sur la taxe chimiques présumées de douma
en syrie en 2018
le 20 janvier dernier une réunion du
conseil de sécurité en formule arria a
été demandée par moscou lors de cet
échange informel vassili n'est benzia
représentant permanent de la russie a
souhaité remettre en question le rapport
de l'organisation pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques sur la taca douma le
7 avril 2018 un bombardement attribué
par l'occident aux troupes de bachar
al-assad avait entraîné la mort de
quelques dizaines de personnes des pays
occidentaux avaient soupçonné une
utilisation d'agents chimiques
l'incident avaient entraîné des frappes
le 13 avril de la part des etats-unis de
la france et du royaume uni sur le
centre de recherche de basée en syrie
les experts de louis ac avaient mené
leur enquête puis publié un court
document préliminaire en juillet 2018
les enquêteurs n'avaient pas trouvé de
traces de gaz sarin mais de produits
chimiques chlorés
après des investigations complémentaires
le rapport final en mars 2019 a statué
ce produit chimique contenait un réactif
du chlore le produit toxique était
vraisemblablement dû clore moléculaire
mais des documents révélés par wikileaks
depuis octobre 2019 ont dévoilé qu'un
ancien expert de loyat c'est ian
henderson avait exprimé des doutes sur
une des analyses du rapport concernant
des cylindres après avoir collecté des
informations sur les lieux du
bombardement
mais il ne faisait pas partie des
experts retenus pour la mission la ffm
laquelle ne lui a jamais demandé des
expertises ian henderson a ensuite
expliqué à des membres de l'onu que le
rapport final constitue un revirement
par rapport aux observations de l'équipe
sur place
les conclusions du rapport final de la
ffm étaient contradictoires était un
revirement complet de ce que l'équipe
avait collectivement déduit pendant et
suivant les enquêtes à la douma et au
moment de la publication du rapport
intermédiaire notre avis était que nous
avions de sérieux doutes sur le fait
qu'une attaque chimique et eu lieu si
l'on excepte henderson aucun membre de
l'équipe de terrain n'a contredit
jusqu'ici le rapport mais ian henderson
reproche à la ffm de n'avoir pas tenu
compte des remarques contradictoires de
son rapport balistique qui l'a envoyé à
l'équipe
l'avs
de la publication du document final le
rapport n'a pas fait toute la lumière
sur les nouvelles découvertes
informations données ou analyses dans le
domaine des témoignages des études
toxicologiques des analyses chimiques
des études d'ingénierie et de balistique
et en définitive a produit un revirement
complet par rapport à ce que la majorité
de l'équipe et l'équipe entière de la
douma penser en juillet 2018
en ce qui me concerne j'ai poursuivi
pendant six mois une étude balistique et
d'ingénierie sur les cylindres qui m'ont
conduit à donner davantage de crédit au
fait qu'il n'y ait pas les attaques si
le rapport de l'eia s'est fait toutefois
mention des analyses balistiques
indépendante de trois pays affirmant que
les cylindres sont bien tombés du ciel
plusieurs membres du conseil de sécurité
ont débattu du témoignage de ian
henderson chacun restant sur ses
positions
oui masse nous devons défendre la
crédibilité et les conclusions de l'oéa
c'est ainsi que les nations unies contre
la désinformation
chamand countries and by the united
states of america
certains pays guidé par les états unis
continuent d'outrepasser les
dispositions de la convention sur
l'interdiction des armes chimiques en
politisant le travail de l'eau eyath et
et en s'écartant de la voix pour
laquelle elle a été créée dirrell from
the tracks et wasquehal y est toutefois
alexander shulgin représentant de la
russie auprès de l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
interroge la crédibilité de l'organisme
et a suggéré une solution proposons une
fois de plus de résoudre ce différend en
organisant une rencontre avec le jass et
avec l'aide possible d état membre
requérant la participation de tous les
membres de la ffm qui ont travaillé sur
le rapport de la dgs main afin de
parvenir enfin à un consensus sur le
sujet de l'incident survenu dans la
ville syrienne ac qui a décliné
l'invitation à cette réunion a
publiquement peu défendu les conclusions
du rapport dont elle dit qu'il se base
sur des analystes
antifi concordantes et alors que les
spéculations émergent seuls les
représentants de cet organisme pourrait
enfin mettre fin à la controverse en
acceptant de s'exprimer prix pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis l ep
avec pierre le corre président de l' ong
we are heroes bonsoir pierre le kof
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on précise pour nos
téléspectateurs calais puis à une
coupure d'électricité
ceci explique l'obscurité dans laquelle
vous vous trouvez mais rassurez vous on
vous voit quand même merci à vous en
tout cas d'être en direct avec nous tout
d'abord pourquoi autant de confusion et
de contradictions sur ce sujet parce
qu'il est évident que le rapport initial
a été entièrement biaisé par par la
suite c'est à dire que ce qui était
écrit au départ par l'équipe qui a
enquêté sur l'attaqué a eu lieu à douma
a été entièrement modifiée ce qui a été
ensuite relayé souligné par un des
enquêteurs qui n'a pas compris ce qui
était en train d'arriver par rapport à
son rapport aux finalement énormément de
faits à bd soit totalement manipulée
soit totalement écrasée t il ya une
chose que finalement les gens ne nage
pas à comprendre et ne peuvent pas
vraiment savoir sans être ici en syrie
c'est le fait que les attaques chimiques
qui a eu lieu que ce soit en 2017 en
2018 n'ont pas pu être justifiée étant
même en 2017 à l'époque de ranchs et 12
n'ont pas pu être justifié par le
gouvernement français nuit par le
gouvernement américain ni par
l'organisation au lycée malheureusement
à travers les documents jusqu'à
maintenant ils ont attesté avoir des
preuves suffisantes mais sans justifier
de ses preuves donc pour moi aujourd'hui
il ya simplement une tentative de
légitimisation des attaques qui ont eu
lieu et légitimisation finalement d'une
propagande pure et dure contre la syrie
contre la russie cette affaire on le
sait est forcément éminemment politique
est très sensible chacun peut-être
s'accusent de manipulation finalement
qui peut-on croire et sur quel fondement
ce qui est très difficile en fait c'est
qu' il faudrait que les personnes
pakistan qui s'intéresserait
au sujet de la syrie est ce qui se passe
aux gens qui vivent aux gens qui
souffrent face leurs propres recherches
finalement il ya énormément de personnes
qui se sont mobilisées pour faire des
recherches complémentaires tant par
rapport aux attaques chimiques qui ont
eu lieu à interoute à la douma où même à
alep l'année dernière puisque nous avons
été bombardés et nous avons été
bombardés pendant toute la guerre par
des armes chimiques mais par les
terroristes c'est à dire que nous nous
recevions ici des des obus et des
roquettes qui était rempli de chlorine
et ça on n'y a assisté l'année dernière
encore nous avons été bombardés ici avec
la plupart des personnes qui ont insisté
à la libération on tue découvrir des
descentes entier de munitions avec des
centaines de sacs de chlorine qui
venaient directement d'arabie saoudite
alors certains vont dire que c'est une
théorie du complot et cetera c'est
impossible évidemment c'est le
gouvernement qui a fait ça chacun ira de
sa de son propre mot mais la réalité sur
le terrain les différentes et chacun si
vous faites des recherches même là le
reporter en chef qui était en charge de
l'enquêté sur la tactique de doom 1 a
totalement remis en question de la bbc a
remis en question cette attaque schmid
en disant eu les vidéos au sein de
l'hôpital ont été entièrement mises en
scène et que d'ailleurs la principale
personne qui filmait la vidéo sans
qu'elle aboubakar annan est l'un des
principaux membres de touche à l'islam
l'armée l'armée d'islam c'est très
difficile finalement de faire la part
des choses
mais ce qui est évident c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces rapports et et ce qui
était arrivé n'ont rien à voir avec avec
la réalité sur toi alors il ya des
personnes à on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure inspecteurs de l'organisation
pour l'interdiction des armes chimiques
a pointé du doigt des conclusions
contradictoires on l'a dit concrètement
de quoi s'agit-il
il est pas mal d'arguments
principalement le fait que les analyses
chimiques ne permettent pas vraiment de
relever les composants qui ont pu être
utilisés second ternant principalement
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas balistique mme
en parlant de preuve que ces cylindres
soit arrivé
du ciel et plus encore important il n'y
a aucune preuve qu'il y a eu une
utilisation chimiques à partir de sept
cylindres
donc il ya eu des relevés chimiques qui
ont eu lieu sur ces cylindres mais il
n'y a aucune preuve comme quoi si l'axé
cylindres auraient été les objets qui
ont délivré une prétendue attaque
chimique
à la fin la réalité c'est que le
l'enquêteur en question qui a remis en
cause les éléments de réécriture du
rapport signifie très clairement que le
rapport ne représente que le plus du
tout le travail d enquête qui a été
réalisée en amont et au départ après l'
attaque
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de preuve
suffisants pour pouvoir justifier de la
tac - si je devais pouvoir en parler
aujourd'hui en tant que personne tant
qu'humanitaires qui est ici il y à
quelque chose qui est arrivé c'est
certain
qu'est ce qui est arrivé comment mon bac
je pense jamais réellement le savoir
par contre il ya une chose qui est
réelle c'est que jusqu'à maintenant il
est évident et je le dis et c'est un
risque que je prends le 10 ans en tant
qu' en tant que français c'est que il
est évident que le gouvernement syrien
ni le gouvernement russes n'ont aucun
intérêt à utiliser l'un chimiques contre
la population syrienne en tout cas
effectivement ces propos n'engagent que
vous vous le dites vous-même vous prenez
un risque en disant ça
qui est selon vous en tout cas cet
ancien inspecteur est on certain de son
indépendance pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent
évidemment il y a beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui qui se sont manifestées
comme lui comme la personne finalement
qui a écrit un anonyme anonymisées et
par le biais de wikileaks wikileaks a
libéré des emails qui permettait de
justifier que l'un des principaux
enquêteurs a induit finalement retraduit
le texte initial en soulignant qu'il y a
des paragraphes qui ont été clairement
effacés et qu'il est allé tournures de
phrases qui ont été clairement modifié
c'est à dire que cet enquêteur
aujourd'hui qui tient à souligner
finalement les éléments qui ont été
retracés par l'enquêteur initiale de
l'adoma ne fait que reprendre des
éléments de preuves qui ont été
constatés par une personne parmi
l'équipe qui était présent sur le site
de la douma et qui a analysé ces
éléments dans balistique scientifiques
etc
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de
possibilité de remettre en question le
témoignage de quelqu'un qui était sur
place qui a analysé le terrain qui a
interviewé les habitants c'est c'est
difficile aujourd'hui que de remettre en
question entre guillemets les éléments
qui sont plus que probants à travers le
texte et surtout de voir la différence
entre le rapport initial et le rapport
est écrit le rapport est écrit il laisse
la possibilité légitime qu'il y ait une
attaque chimique le rapport initial
laisse clairement de sous-entendre qu'il
n'y a aucune
si l'utilisation à deux auri de tout
élément qui pourrait être chic
merci merci pierre le corre d'avoir été
avec nous en direct depuis allaitent
merci à vous nous avoir exprimé en tout
cas votre opinion
[Musique]